hello ladies and gentlemen and welcome
to Rotten Tomatoes binge battle this is
the show where we have two combatants
from the world of online pond and tree
and they're gonna come together and go
tete-a-tete in an argument that today
might break Facebook because it's Game
of Thrones folks that's what we're
arguing here today all sorts of stuff
characters the storylines and everything
else in between Game of Thrones the show
that brought fantasy back to the
mainstream the show that helped give
Starbucks one of their best advertising
boosts in the last two decades that show
is gonna be argued here and I have two
esteemed colleagues here that our Game
of Thrones monster fans and they have
some strong thoughts if you saw the
practice round that aren't always
positive about the show that they dearly
loved so much introducing first you can
see her just over to my right to your
right maybe your left that is the one
the only producer and talent at
iHeartRadio and you've seen her writing
and everything from vogue to the
Highwood reporter she well Monique how
you doing to that hi I'm really good
when you guys came even Game of Thrones
I was like finally like something fun to
do in this quarantine I'm really looking
forward to this yeah last week we we
were debating lost and like lost has you
know controversial final season and all
that stuff but I feel like loss as a
show was just a warm-up to how we were
all gonna react to Game of Thrones and
your opponent today Joe well he is a man
that I have had the pleasure of
announcing a number of his matches
usually he's in the winning team for the
movie trivia Schmo down a former
champion in that league and he just
launched nerds in suits which is a nice
kind of conglomeration of all of his new
shows he has been the boss Bateman how
you doing bud I'm doing great mark I'm
I'm so flattered that you that you you
know what I'm doing you're paying
attention that's incredible I noticed
that with the people that are voting for
me they give a heart Joe well just get a
thumbs up so I think you know deck is
stacked but I'm excited today that's
right yeah I think everybody's being a
little standoffish in this day and age
and maybe alike is all you need because
look I won both y'all the Internet's
gonna tell one of you that they like you
but they don't
of you and the other one that they're
gonna reward with being the winner of
today's match that's right folks you
determine who wins the bench battle here
in the world of Game of Thrones so the
way that you do that is Joelle and Ben
are both gonna presents arguments and a
variety of rounds four rounds in total
unless we go to sudden death overtime we
do have a fifth round ready in that
event you're gonna click like that blue
thumbs up button if you think Joelle had
the better more compelling argument or
you liked her answer better or you just
feel like hitting the like button
conversely everything Ben Bateman had
the better choice have the better
argument throughout the round then you
click that heart button I'd also love to
see y'all's comments and I will be
reading some of them throughout the
duration of the show because as the Game
of Thrones creators know the fans are
very opinionated about this and let's
let those opinions flow in a nice calm
setting like Facebook so without further
ado we're about to get into the first
round of binge battle but I do want to
remind everybody out there that at any
time you can hit up rottentomatoes.com
they certainly have a lot of Game of
Thrones info on there but you can also
check out binge central you just click
on that and that's kind of our hub for
all things that are streaming right now
and that's the way we digest our
entertainment especially in this
pandemic so enjoy all the latest movies
stuff all the new TV shows and a lot of
cool lists that you can check out ok
enough preamble let's get into this
let's get it on our round number one
topic is who is the best character in
Game of Thrones history well if you
thought we were throwing a softball with
the practice round this one's gonna get
tough and this one is gonna get
controversial so Ben Bateman you lost
the practice round but that also is
going to give you the kickoff that you
just received to do round number one
first you got about a minute on the
clock hit me with your favorite
character the best character in Game of
Thrones is obviously the Arya Stark it
would be hard not to pick one of the
stark sisters I think there's a few
other great characters but at the end of
the day when you think about the best
episodes of Game of Thrones the best
arcs even the best spin-off
opportunities they all seem to come back
to Arya she's the only character from
the beginning of the show that clearly
rejects the system she rejects the
politics she rejects the game of Thrones
and she goes and plays her own game she
goes and learns from many many sort of
father figures from you know mother
figures throughout the show she trains
with people she learns different skill
sets always inquisitive always fierce
and at the end of the day vicious just
somebody who really you know when you
watch her on the road with the Hound and
she's she's instructing the Hound you
know don't kill that guy
we should have sympathy later on
laughing maniacally when she hears the
death of another family member she's
just somebody who's so affected by the
environment she's in she becomes the
most the most deep the most ruthless and
really the most cunning character who
really rejects the system but shines
because of it and I think it makes her
unique and ultimately the best character
in Game of Thrones this is so much fun
because as soon as we postulated best
character the chat room lit up with like
900 different answers so it's gonna be a
fun debate here today Jill well I think
I might take area Stark and the Hound in
a buddy cop movie together but as far as
best standalone character who's your
pick so it's gonna be a battle between
the stark sisters today because my pick
is Sansa Stark here's why you want to
say vicious sounds to start doesn't
start off it's just but by the end she
balls her like a tormentor to death with
dogs
daggers she takes a Kingdom essentially
from her brother
no like people left in her way she's on
a mission and what I really like about
Sansa is that if we look at the world of
fantasy early fantasy had only like
naive princesses waiting to be saved
later fantasy you get a ton of like
badass hard ladies doing it for
themselves which is awesome but sounds
like it's there's a great combination of
both and therefore becomes one of the
most real characters you have this young
girl who wants to like fall in love and
wants to be a queen and wants to do all
the things a lot of sort of pinch to
little girls as the ultimate life
fantasy and then she's thrown to the
wolves and learns what reality is like
we explore the way women have to deal
with being sexualized at early ages how
they manage to negotiate the way they
are seen and we see her blossom after
she gets with Littlefinger and she
figures out how to manipulate him she's
manipulating governments and she goes
back and essentially wins award for the
North takes over and becomes an epic
excellent leader he doesn't just reject
the game of Thrones which she wins it
she is the breaker of wheels she is our
queen love thumbs up best character in
Game of Thrones
okay so it is a battle of the sisters
and then I want to go back to you for a
quick
point here Joelle's really arguing that
Sansa has the more interesting character
art do you think that aria has got a
better art than her sister I do i think
that aria zark is more interesting
because it's less predictable you have
to sort of have a character in the songs
a role in the story of Game of Thrones
otherwise the show wouldn't be
compelling on the way to the throne I
think science is an incredible character
I think saans it would be a great answer
if you asked me several other questions
some of which I don't want to give
Joelle fuel here with but I do think
that Aria because in the final season or
two actually does get to politic she
gets to be a part of the politics at the
end as the sisters are attempt to be
played against each other by
Littlefinger she has a significant part
in playing her role to get Littlefinger
ultimately executed not to mention the
fact that she takes out the freaking
night king a big throwback to a oh and
in Lord of the Rings I mean she she is
the killer of like come on you can't
beat artists she's the best character
okay yeah pretty convincing argument
there by been a Joelle your counterpoint
to Ben's argument well Arya has a very
incredible art she's not any more unique
than any other pirate adventurer from
any other fantasy she slashes her way to
victory and she finds out she has a
heart but Jesus is still like it belongs
to the sea and goes back out there this
is a story we've seen time and time
again typically I think what sounds a
storyline what you see are women either
falling in love into like a healthy
relationship or they're dead so I don't
think there's anything predictable about
what happened with Sansa I think most
people thought she was going he was evil
terror and she turns him to something
completely different
I think she's unique and gorgeous and
again a true queen of the north amazing
alright it's something you're describing
neither until you went with the queen of
the north a unique and gorgeous or two
traits that I like to claim so one more
time gonna remind everybody if you think
Joelle had the better argument hit that
like button hit that blue thumbs up if
you think Ben is gonna win round number
one or that's who you'd like to see hit
that heart hit the red button so we go
to fine arguments now Ben I'm gonna give
you about 10-15 seconds is it summary
for Arya Stark ultimately at the end of
the day I think your point just a minute
ago about Sansa being gorgeous because
he's exactly the reason that I think
Arya is such an interesting character
she's not presented as the beautiful
elegant princess she's a tomboy from the
early age of the show goes on to become
the most fearsome character and then
stands by her sisters side at the
of the show the way she's presented
doesn't fit consistently with really any
of the ways that those princess
characters and major shows tend to fit
and I like her more for that reason it's
close love Sansa
Ari's a little better all right well the
Rotten Tomatoes official Facebook page
just commented that Mark Ellis is the
queen of the north so thanks for that
new online nickname Joelle you are
defending the real Queen of the north 15
seconds is all yours to close out round
number one Sansa surviving Ramsay Bolton
stepping into her own light becoming a
ruler defying her brother her beauty is
second nature to all of the things that
she accomplishes in such a short time
she learns from everyone she interacts
with so that she can become a good ruler
not run off and go do her own thing she
stays with her family and keeps Ned
Stark's legacy alive and really if he's
the character were introduced to he's
the first character that dies that sort
of shocks us I think it's what makes her
incredible for her to continue on his
like see her mother's legacy it's got to
be some stark okay so the chat room is
lit up and predictably so I'm seeing a
lot of great comments here and a lot of
great support for both arguments from
Joelle and Ben my favorite comment is
probably from Donna Hoffer who says
Sansa is the best character but Tyrion
is the most beloved by audiences with
Arya being a close second unrelated
Donna says she will die salty about what
they did to Denarius petering Demaryius
chances of entering this argument but
after all of that hubbub and it was a
great opening round by both competitors
Ben Bateman has gotten more votes than
Joelle so Ben goes up 1-nothing in binge
battle Game of Thrones Edition and we
move on to your next category so your
acceptance speech here mark or no no
it's very early in the game even Thrones
fans know anything it's just whoever is
waiting early maybe that doesn't bode
well for your chances later on in the
game
but we are gonna go to the most shocking
death okay I mean this show is littered
with them there is you may have more
[ __ ] death Joelle then characters to
pick from for round number one so it's a
new round you're cooking like for Joelle
you're cooking love for Ben Joe well
you're gonna kick this round off with
your most shocking death what do you got
for me okay
Talia Stark now why did I choose a
character some of you wouldn't remember
the name for Talia stark if you don't
remember was the pregnant future Queen
of the north who dies at the red wedding
we've seen so many deaths up to Talia's
but what makes her as particularly
disturbing is the way in which she's
killed we have never ever seen a person
killed like this odd we stabbed in the
belly while pregnant devastating if we
look at the arc of that storing line but
just the deaths within that scene it's
like oh it's soldiers tickling soldiers
oh no Riley's been hit what do we do and
then it's her and you understand the
shattering of innocence you understand
that the legacy the very last hope of
the stark family at this point
bolsters and brace aria is right outside
the gate she's almost there and now
there's no hope left for us like we have
to go all the way back and start from
zero and her death is the pinnacle of
that scene it's incredible it's a
devastating loss I still not over it
clearly it's an emotional thing and
we're still recovering collectively as a
people from the events of the red
wedding so Talia Stark I'll be honest
the name didn't hit me initially but as
soon as you said red wedding I did the
math and I was like oh right that was
like the worst death of all the ones
that took place that evening Ben Bateman
you're going against Joelle what is your
most shocking death in a game of Thrones
war you know the Denese you mentioned
Joelle may be shocking but certainly not
memorable I believe the characters
proper name is Tallis ax it's with an S
and that should be proof of just how
irrelevant of a character that truly was
to kill now the real shocking part is
the fact that the unborn child young
Eddard Stark that would they wanted to
run around with that's the real shocking
death my shocking death of course is
going to be the single most shocking
death in the history of television Ned
Stark it is a moment in TV history when
we all collectively gasped wondered what
was going to be the reveal that could
show us somehow this didn't actually
happen but it did it actually happened
they killed the main character of the
show on HBO's hottest new show I
couldn't believe it
I could my job was on the floor I think
as most people's were and it started to
actually change the paradigm of
television going forward with what we
could do the expectation of a premium
show not to mention the fact that bar
Amir who had died a lot of rings was
resurrected as Ned Stark he's the best
character in the trilogy he comes back
in this show I'm so excited to watch him
and they take him out my mind was blown
barmy are dead twice Sean beans the man
it's the most shocking death of all time
in history television yeah I do remember
watching that episode in our pre-show I
mentioned that that was the first
episode I actually watched of Game of
Thrones and I remember thinking like
okay how's old bean gonna get out of
this one didn't happen like that and
that they know set us up for more
shocking deaths but were they more
shocking or were they just other
shocking deaths so Joe well how do you
counter Ben's argument where he claimed
that the deaths of that stark is maybe
the most compelling dramatic shocking
moment in TV history I will absolutely
agree that net starts death is the first
shocking death and Game of Thrones it
certainly sets the tone for the rest I
think the ability to shock us after that
is what makes tell us his death show
like just like horrifying and
heartbreaking the idea that like she's
insignificant is a ridiculous at the
time she's a love interest she's set to
be queen she's abandoned her family does
she stack up in the entire game of
Thrones no but neither does the mountain
and who is he killed the Viper the Viper
and long sea beans in there for season
and a half but his death still
horrifyingly shocking I think when we
are still able to be shocked after his
death after we know that anyone's game
that to me sets a very high bar and you
know just the fact that we saw it at the
red wedding that it's the pinnacle of
those deaths I think arguably more
shocking than Ned's death it's a pretty
interesting way that Joelle frames had
been is that it's harder to shock people
in the later seasons than it would be in
the first season yeah I will stick to my
claim here that I think though the scene
is shocking and horrible I mean very uh
terrifying scenes you all agree with you
I do really believe it's not Tallis's
death that's so shocking I actually
think it's the death of the unborn child
but is the more shocking of the two
deaths maybe it's a technicality but you
could have chosen the unborn child of
Eddard Stark
I really do truly honestly believe that
when looking
back on the show the red wedding will be
remembered as an important episode and a
scene but the death of Ned Stark will be
remembered as a more important death and
definitely a more shocking one in the
history of television
proving my Game of Thrones knowledge
that episode is called the rains of
castamere that red wedding I knew that
because I had to do the research for the
trivia question which somebody wanted
fandango now promo code courtesy of so
setting the table once again click those
like buttons click the blue thumbs up if
you think Joelle has the better argument
click the red heart for Ben if you think
he should win round number 2 we're gonna
go to the final arguments Joelle you got
about 10 seconds for one last dance with
Talia
Talisa whatever her name is Ned Stark
was a prisoner of two of the most evil
characters on Game of Thrones
like what's his death shocking at the
time sure no one expected it but we I
don't even think after Ned's death we
get that silent treatment that we get
after the red wedding and I still think
that if there's no amount of separating
Hausa from her unborn child at this
point they are one person so that Erik
Stark is a more shocking death than dead
then tazza also has to fall into that
category okay Ben Bateman you're closing
out round number two the likes and the
hearts are flying fast and furious
what's your final argument I've made all
my points against the talus of death the
biggest point for the Ned Stark death
being as shocking as it is is that his
insistence to play by the rules to be
this nobleman when he dies it proves to
you that's not how the show is gonna
work you're gonna have to politic and
you're gonna have to politic hard if you
don't want to die and that's what the
next seven seasons of the show is gonna
be about it set the tone for the
greatest television show in modern
history
all right well like I said it's gonna
happen in all the arguments here today
chat room agreeing with both of you all
at times but also they have their own
opinion like Brandon Cole who says I
can't believe no one mentioned the Viper
but we did mention the Viper but nobody
took the Vipers death jens wax says
overran for sure would be her answer for
the most shocking death and it really
does come down to a question of well
what is more shocking is it's something
that happens when we're getting to know
a show or is it something that still
shocks us after we already know that
that show can set us up for twists and
turns
it appears that Facebook
is signing with Joelle Monique in round
number two though it may be I wouldn't
consider been losing in round two to be
quite as shocking as either Ned or
talents abut it was a good argument
presented all the way around and it's
really easy for me because we get to
keep the drama going one-to-one as we
head into round and number three round
number three is known as the best battle
round
okay so Game of Thrones gives us these
huge sprawling epic army vs. army vs
army vs army battles that we also have
these really cool interpersonal moments
that feel like a huge boxing match so
then I'm gonna go back to you to start
this argument best battle in Game of
Thrones so I thought long and hard about
this one mark and what I ultimately came
up with was that I think the impact of a
single death in a fight is more
impactful than any of the major battles
in the show which is why I picked
ultimately the fight between the viper
over in Martell and the mountain it is
the most compelling fight in the entire
show and has far and away the most
horrifying ending to a battle in the
show's history it on re-watch my heart
started beating I almost vomited
it's that upsetting to watch the ending
not to mention the fact that the
mountain played by a guy whose name is
pretty much unpronounceable by me it's
like Bjorn Jorgen Morgenson that's he's
the world's strongest man he's won that
competition like three times he lists
boulders the size of me and you watch
him crush someone's head in the show I
mean that's that's frightening that's
that's terrifying it's compelling and
the fight itself is incredible the
stages he's so much bigger that is a
better fight and a better battle than
anything else that ever happens in the
show and ultimately more memorable than
any other medicine I love this round
because it's reminding me my favorite
part of Game of Thrones joelle is like
the build-up is great and all the drama
and the interpersonal relationships and
the conniving the backstabbing but once
we get to these epic battle scenes or
these interpersonal ones like what Ben
just said so that's a great pull from
Ben how
counter that what is your best battle in
Game of Thrones if this were best fight
I would not have an argument for men
would have chosen absolutely the best
fighting game of Thrones oh we're
talking battles and battles are huge and
they are against armies and the Battle
of the bastards is by far and away the
best battle and Game of Thrones history
it rivals cinematic battles like helms
deep Saving Private Ryan long battle
we're talking Costra phobia inducing
battles tight shots
I think they spend two months filming
this it is so intense some of the best
music that rummy does shot I'm so sorry
series name on - I'll be right right
bastards in this those big thick heavy
drums is John is like searching up to
get Ramsey it shows how Sansa is a great
ruler of the North how she's prepared to
battle and the fact that John is super
strong but also on last legs the way we
see them just slinging in the mud and
snow
everything about battle of the bastards
is big and epic and impactful and if you
don't leave remembering how you felt
after that like you needed a very long
cold shower and a lot of water and a big
breath like it is not a lot of film
scenes that touch you like that and to
do it in a fight to tell a story through
battle incredibly challenging and they
do it it's wonderful yeah I think like
all great like epic army on army battle
scenes you get this huge shot this
perspective of everybody but you also
get that cool shot at Jon Snow which is
basically him versus everyone else so it
both great pulls better gonna go back to
you if you're watching right now and you
want to get in on the conversation if
you think then has the better argument
vote with your heart everything Joelle
vote with your thumbs up like for Joelle
love for Ben so been 30 seconds tell me
why this interpersonal battle means more
than the Battle of the bastards all the
way the battle the bastards is cinematic
it's fantastic but it happens for stupid
reasons I mean Rickon can't run zigzags
which is why Jon runs out into the field
it's kind of a stupid decision by John
in the first place he doesn't listen to
Sansa so it's really just a plot device
so the sounds that can come save him I
mean it's got just a bad decision by
resurrected Jon whereas all of the
stakes that are set up by the Viper vs
the mountain fight are great I mean
Tyrion has another champion fighting for
him after we've already seen it happen
once successfully and the mountain
who is the show's biggest character the
actual biggest character gets to exhibit
truly that he's the world's strongest
men and the strongest person in all of
Westeros that's not a giant I just think
it's a much more memorable single moment
in the show that doesn't lean on the
theatrics and the theatricality of a
huge battle which looks great
but is way less memorable yeah the
mountain actually did play professional
basketball in Europe right so so well we
go back to you for your counterpoint
it's a big sweeping battle but do you
agree with Ben that the decision-making
was so questionable it cost some of the
dramatic value of the battle now how
many wars have been fought over stupid
things all of the time what I love about
it cinematically and thematically it's
effective two guys trying so hard to be
accepted in their roles as leaders and
to see them have been shunned by their
fathers in different ways for different
reasons to see their struggles to fit
into their family and honor their sigils
finally come to a head over a land back
to us as the viewers the first face
we've been introduced you it's so vital
and important and I really love the idea
of like David Benioff and DB Weiss
having culminated like the horrors of
what humans can do to each other and the
importance of land and family I mean
honestly bel the Basterds was our
penultimate final and we have ended here
it would have been so much better people
have connected to all of the main fiends
that is clear they cared about and that
drove the story we see all of that in
battle of the bastards and that's what
makes it so impressive this is good
stuff we got going there's so many great
comments in the chat room I want to
highlight before we get to the fun
arguments Rachael Spaulding is joining
us says just started watching the entire
series on season 2 right now well keep
watching it because it's a great show
and Rachael says can we have a prequel
series I think we actually might have
something to the works for you Rachel so
that's a little sidebar once again vote
with your heart with your red button for
Ben but with the blue button with your
thumbs up light for Joelle Ben you got
about 10-15 seconds to tell me why
Mountain Viper is the best
I think what's the difference between a
battle and a fight you can you can
semantics me all day long if you want to
tell me that a battle means something
different than a fight but I know that
the confrontation between the two
characters I'm talking about is more
impactful as a fight not as a setting
the battle setting the battle
of the bastards is something people talk
about in the same way that the red
wedding is what that scenes about not
the actual death of Talas the fight
between the two characters that I'm
talking about is more important
ultimately and memorable than the actual
large-scale set-piece you're talking
about
okay so Joelle the final word goes to
you you mentioned that you would love to
have the Battle of bastards to be the
last thing we saw in Game of Thrones
well you get to have the last word
defending said battle so have at it
Jon Snow has fought up until this time
to be a leader and be seen and be
respected and it's been hard he's been
stabbed it's been ugly here's where he
proves himself and he proves himself not
just to himself not just to his family
but to his men which i think is the most
vital thing to Jon Snow and as the
person that we're relying on to complete
the mission of Ned Stark that guy we
lost in season one this is his moment
and so it's grand and it's epic and it's
fitting and it works and I think it
drives the story home and it takes out
two of our biggest baddies in the entire
series this is the battle that ends
Littlefinger and it's the battle that
ends Ramsay Ryan Chandler says that his
favorite battle was the one that you
couldn't see without adjusting your
televisions nice little inside nod there
don't worry Rachel you'll get to that
episode
Eileen Rivera says the Battle of the
bastards was her favorite
Gerardo has a great point he says he
goes with Joe well that the scene where
John is trapped underneath the crowd of
soldiers and giant getting killed with
all those arrows is just epic so it
appears that the epic battle won this
time that Joe elf now goes up two-to-one
on Ben battle the bastards edging out
mountain versus Viper look I'd consider
both of them epic battles and I don't
think that the semantics between a
battle and a fight could cost either
competitor anything in this round I
think that both our all-time great in
the pantheon of Game of Thrones but the
Battle of the bastards the crowd went
epic and joelle now enjoys a two to one
lead but then don't worry you can come
back in this round if you can tell me
who ultimately in round number four is
our question should have sat on the Iron
Throne so many contenders it was like a
reality show you have so many different
people waiting to get that one crown so
then who should that crown ultimately
have belonged to you see what's great
about this argument mark is that
basically Joelle made this argument for
me two rounds ago when she talked about
how great of a character Sansa was every
argument she made for Sansa in that
round is pretty much what qualifies her
to be the person that should have sat on
the Iron Throne it's often been said
that a ruler that doesn't want to rule
is the best kind and because she only
ever really wanted to rule in the north
it makes her over qualified in the final
scene and in the final season when she's
talking to her uncle and he's like let
me tell you about my qualifications and
she's like uncle sit down she just like
has the venom she sees people who they
are it's right in the face of Daenerys
the first time she meets her and if you
go all the way back to the first season
when she's meeting Joffrey it's so
tragic to look at the way she looks at
Joffrey those innocent eyes she trains
under all these different great
characters in the show be she becomes a
victim she becomes a hero she becomes a
ruler she becomes a warrior and she
learns from the best which is what makes
her ultimately qualified to truly sit on
the throne after having played the game
nobody else in the show that lives at
the end has played the game successfully
and maintained their sense of good that
would make them the qualified person to
sit on that throne she's a true queen
and deserves to be the ruler at the end
of the show
okay so Ben Bateman leaning heavily into
the Sansa should be on the iron throne
debate Jo hell are you gonna go full
Freaky Friday on me and take Arya and
then just basically switched your picks
from round one that would be well but no
I'm gonna go with Tyrion Lannister
should have sat on the throne listen
Sansa Stark is the true queen of the
north and she deserves to rule there
she's an excellent queen but you can't
take a queen of the north who's loyal to
the north who will make very
questionable decisions for the people of
the north as we saw her do with John
when John was like listen we gotta give
let these kids keep their home and she's
like no screw them their dad was a
trader so therefore their trader so
therefore we're giving that house to
somebody who was loyal to us she will
always pick the north over everybody
else he cannot rule from the center of
the kingdom with one nation state in
mind it's going to cause chaos you're
gonna get killed girl it's not good on
the other hand Tyrion has been hand to
not one but two monarchs he has gone
through so many failings he and we have
seen the darkest part
of him and he's come out of that a
better person a smarter person a person
ready and willing to rule he has spent
time all over Westeros so he's familiar
with all the countries their customs
their leaders and we know that he
understands the art of politicking so
extremely well that he and we've seen
him role as a shadow king essentially
and do great things for the kingdom he
won the battle that they had in season
two
he's just clearly the superior thinker
and tactician and I think those are the
two things that you really want as your
leader of Westeros
all right once again we have Tyrion
versus Sansa and the chat room is
already not agreeing with either two or
back Gendry I have someone for bran
big fan Owen says Denarius should be on
the Iron Throne and Joel Mears says me
Joel thinks he should be on the Iron
Throne oh maybe that's First Season
seven or eight Joe in the meantime been
gonna go back to you for a little more
Sansa what's your rebuttal to Joelle's
argument for Tyrion great picture well I
mean Tyrion is probably the most beloved
character in the entire show however not
a good king not a good ruler first and
foremost he's drunk all the time and he
Philander's and spends most of his time
in brothels I mean great TV character
not a great king not somebody that I
would want to be my king I'd be
terrified if that guy was my king what
he's trying to make battle decisions
when he's hammered that's not a good
thing all right on top of which on top
of which you got a look at the way the
people are going to react to their ruler
and in Westeros where the people have
proven that they do not respect him just
because of his size which is not fair
they won't follow him they revolt he's a
tremendous hand of the king and an
incredible thinker but not somebody who
fits the bill in Westeros to be the king
which is why I actually think she should
have sat on throne cuz I think she could
keep it I don't think he'd be able to
keep the throne
I think he'd lose it okay so joelle been
basically saying that while Tyrians
behavior maybe does sum up some
politicians behavior maybe not fitting
for a king
of a TV show give me why Tyrion would be
a better ruler than Sansa well then I
would agree with you if he were talking
about the Tyrion of seasons one through
five
the guy who was tormented by his father
abused by his sister neglected by
everyone was an alcoholic I'm not a good
boy Tony who grows and comes out of that
develops learns to lead Nations has had
durable experiences and reinforces
themselves as a power of good that's
exactly who I'd want leading my nation I
think all of the bad things that you
rien had to go through make him the
perfect monarch and cheer you no comment
about how people might react to him but
you looked at our actual history which
we know Game of Thrones is based in a
lot of history Richard the third you
know had some deformities in his leg and
he had hump back still a leader not a
great leader but still life and change
some eyes I think when we put people who
we don't expect in positions of power
we often get a change in society so we
knew Westeros would be better after King
Tyrion let them all right I'm feeling
either way however this debate goes
you're gonna see a lot of hashtags not
my king um vote with your thumbs up but
with your blue button for Joelle getting
she is the better argument with Ben the
red heart is the button you want to
click and show your support Ben Bateman
gonna go to you for your final argument
give me about 10-15 seconds stumping for
Sansa the first character we meet in
Game of Thrones is Ned Stark a true
nobleman a man who's whose children
should be the one sitting on the throne
at the end of the day the Lannisters
they're tricksters they're people that
tricked their way into the positions
they're in they politic the way into the
positions they're in and they're not
honest
they shouldn't be where they are in the
first place the Starks are noble Sansa
Stark she's the better ruler than Tyrion
even though Tyrion I honestly think is a
better character I like Tyrion more but
Sansa deserve to sit on throne ok joelle
final word goes to you for your boy
Tyrion yeah Tyrion has the best interest
everybody else at heart he's really
selfish or self-centered
he's old wiser and happy chance to back
up key and when people get to know him
and he gets a chance to prove himself
almost inevitably they love him Sansa is
an amazing ruler for the North that
people love her and she loves her people
but she cannot rule all of Westeros with
a worth way of thinking it's going to
say okay so all right let me get y'all's
take on this real quick that somebody
postulated
the night king should have been the the
fitting ruler at the end of the show can
Ichi I'll just give you start with you
band then go to Joelle not for points
I'm just curious give me about 10
seconds should the night does that make
sense
I mean look he can resurrect the dead so
nobody ever dies inevitability is king
he's a king he can he's got a sweet
dragon the ice dragon it's one of the
coolest looking images in the whole show
it's like having a great car right no I
don't think it'd be a good king a good
king no a king that would have made
sense for the ending of this season
absolutely we've seen time and time
again that brutality wins in the game of
Thrones and there was no one more brutal
than the night king also I think when
you can just touch people and now they
have to follow you it doesn't seem like
the walking zombies have a choice
it makes sense that he would be you know
a firm leader good no great probably
okay you voted with your hearts you
voted with your heads before we get to
the results Lucy if it's Joan has my
favorite comment and this round saying I
wanted that bald guy to rule that got
killed by the Dragons I love that Lucy
because then it's a loose enough
description to where Rachael didn't have
anything spoiled for because she's only
on season 2 that being said the votes
are in and this is as close as they come
folks but by the narrowest of margins we
have ourselves a tie and we are going to
sudden-death
Ben bacon and his son's a star club is
going up and tying Joelle at two to two
and once again here on binge battle we
have a sudden-death category so outcome
it's gonna be okay you're voting the
same way you did in regulation accept
the argument gonna be a little quicker
so Ben Joe I'm gonna give you the round
and what the topic is then you each get
an opening minute like normal and then
you only have your closing arguments as
the last straw
in it so if you're prepared and ready I
know it's been exhausting anybody need
to breathe anybody need to take a sip of
water y'all ready to go to get in this
good to go man
I love having you on the show
round number five sudden death it's
gonna be started by Joelle and it is the
subject of the worst character Oh
Oh negative with a game of Thrones topic
okay Joe well the minute is yours who's
the worst character in Game of Thrones I
works as an evil and might pick his
little finger listen this is a guy who
would sell out his mother if it meant
that he could get some coin and a little
bit of advantage
he picked the love of his life daughter
to essentially groom into his lover
slash queen then sold her to a rapist
who slays his victims alive and then
pressed back in like he was all Zapata
cooks like no it's totally fine
he's got no concept of what it means to
be a good person a good friend of the
parental figure a good leader a good
adviser any please all of those roles he
is monstrous in all of his actions and
he never feels bad about them ever he
has no remorse or soul to speak of
Littlefinger is by far and away one of
the best players in Game of Thrones but
he's absolutely one of the worst people
okay so then you agree with that
argument I have a feeling you'd own the
worst character in Game of Thrones I'm
gonna pick the rapist you mentioned who
filets his victims Ramsay Bolton he is a
horrible character both he is evil but
he's also badly developed I think he
actually fits both bills he's the most
cartoonishly evil character in the show
he feels like they killed Joffrey and
they needed somebody to just be kind of
bad and evil at all times so they just
gave us Ramsay he's just not very
interesting any of the back story scenes
begin with Ramsay were supposed to
develop why he is the way there and
nobody remembers those they just
remember him laughing and like torturing
people that's like basically all
Ramsay's good for so the end of the day
when I look back on Game of Thrones I
barely even remember Littlefinger as
evil he seems just kind of like another
awesome piece of the chessboard he's he
is evil sure but he's a great piece he's
no more evil to me than Cersei is evil
or most of the characters are evil
whereas Ramsay just sucks and is badly
developed and is evil and it's
cartoonishly bad that feels like a
bumper sticker Ramsay just sucks Ramsay
Bolton certainly I wouldn't really want
to hang out with either one of these two
fellas at a party I wouldn't trust
either one of them as far as I can throw
them but now we've almost come to that
time so remember you're voting with your
blue thumbs up like button
Joell if you want her to win not only
the round but also the match here on
binge ballet you're voting for Ben
Bateman by clicking that heart the red
button and Joelle the time has come for
your final argument tell me once again
your best reason why Littlefinger is the
worst character in Game of Thrones
Ramsay's evil is orchestrated in such a
way to show us the worst possible person
from an evil perspective and then we get
the backstory of him I don't know what
Ben's talking about I learned a lot
about Ramsay's backstory as he was
torturing reek and it all was because
we've seen his father we he formed
himself into the ideals of his community
it says how we treat boys what we teach
them about the ways are expected to
react is how they're going to absorb
those things and behave in the world
I think Ramsey has a very important role
to play do I think he's more evil than
Littlefinger No Littlefinger's evil is
not to serve a higher good or a purpose
of action or family or Kingdom is simply
to serve himself and know Ramsay's worst
actions can be carried out unless
Littlefinger orchestrates him he's the
guy behind scenes pulling all the
strings and while Ramsay the things he
does looks awful probably feel awful
with Littlefinger there's no warning
there's no way you can see him coming
unless you've already been hurt by him
that is some next-level
evil stuff like you can see Ramsay
coming a mile away
dark hair slaying people stalks me
there's no way to avoid the kind of evil
that Littlefinger is and that makes him
truly devious okay Ben gonna give you
about 45 seconds to a minute as well a
close up shop here and give us your
final argument for Ramsay when I think
about the scenes that little fingers in
and the show Game of Thrones they're
mostly pretty delightful I would never
want the character to not be in the show
he's great to watch he's really more of
a love to hate type of character because
every time he does something dastardly
you look at him and you think man this
show has just made so much better by
this evil character sure he's
orchestrating horrible things but it
feels like the ecosystem that his Game
of Thrones needs players like that when
I think of Ramsay I just want him to die
every time I think about the character
I'm like I can't wait for this guy to
die cuz he sucks the scenes that he's in
aren't very good they're really brutal
they're there
like dude they're setting backs on set
as a character they literally put her in
scenes with him and it's like I'm and
everything that was great about this
character that was developing so nicely
is ruined by this idiot ramsey so all i
want to see it the whole time is just to
watch him die
I wanted to be off the show and I want
to replaced by something he has a little
bit more depth and a little bit more
interesting your character you chose is
truly more interestingly evil than my
character but my character is both evil
and bad like just a bad character on the
show I don't think I keep coming back to
it because when I think about it I would
never want to re-watch the Ramsay
episodes but I love the little finger
stuff it feels like an essential piece
of Game of Thrones and one that I
wouldn't be able to live without so
ultimately I got to say Ramsay is a
worst character on all fronts I will say
it wasn't Ramsay Bolton episode of Game
of Thrones that got me the closest to
throwing up my dinner watching what was
going on on-screen but I managed to keep
it on me and I think that Ben and Joelle
can at least agree on the fact that
Ramsey or Littlefinger if you find one
of them hitchhiking do not pick them up
just keep driving down the road as fast
as you can but unfortunately the way
things work here on binge battle we
can't give it to both parties only one
can wear the crown on the Iron Throne
and we do have a winner you voted with
your legs for Joelle you voted with your
hearts for Ben and maybe it was that
last Action Army push that put Ben
pavement over the top is our winner
congratulations Ben Bateman you're in
the winner's circle
feels good mark it feels really good I'd
like to thank a few people here if I you
give me a second here I'd like to thank
my fan I'm just kidding Joe Ellis was so
much fun playing against you so get
throw back to our old or old sure Motown
days was nice to go up against you three
years later but that was that was really
a lot of fun so thanks everybody for
watching definitely you told her I
remember now what a great battler you
are I was with you you definitely did
not disappoint you brought it all I
would have definitely voted with you on
a couple he all had great arguments and
it was so much fun watching the chatroom
keep up with you all because look at the
chat room they have to vote for one of
y'all but that doesn't mean they have to
agree with either pic and so they gave
us a lot of other options and I think
that maybe 20 years from now there will
be a 10 part documentary
on this episode of binge battle because
it had just that many twists and turns
and drama so first and foremost I do
want to thank all of the fans for
showing up in force and watching us here
today and I want to remind y'all check
out rottentomatoes.com that's where you
can go to binge central it's such a
great guide for all things streaming
right now there's so many cool lists
they did a list of like a hundred best
comedies of all time they threw in a
sports movies ones that you know I loved
and as well as a lot of TV streaming
information too so it's just your hub
for all things binging right now Rotten
Tomatoes calm at binge central thanks to
our partners it's Fandango now for
giving away those promo codes for all
the trivia questions and of course thank
you to both Ben and Joelle Ben you are a
winner here today and once again
congrats on the new endeavor with nerds
and suits I didn't know that I could
call this show a great conversation it
was a great debate but you have a new
show called a great conversation that
maybe he's a little more congenial than
what we had today I do man thank you so
much for that yeah nerds in suits is a
dream of mine for a long time to launch
it it's up now you can find him on
youtube.com slash nerds in suits and
more so really thank you to everybody
that was in the chat from Action Army
from Action industries the branded a
with Android guy I saw a lot of familiar
names in there that may be really happy
to see that so thanks for shouting that
out and yeah thanks for watching guys
and Ben I can't let you go without a
couple maybe Streaming recommendations
that you have for all the folks watching
us at home we've all we've seen Game of
Thrones for the most part so what else
is on your dial it's a must watch we
really enjoyed the the prime show
Goliath that shows a big fan of that one
I've got a friend in that show Billy Bob
is fantastic in that show it feels like
that that classic like 90s you know that
that 90s like courtroom stuff it's it's
really fun to watch I enjoy that one a
lot I'm just going back now and rewashed
all of better call Saul as well because
I absolutely freaking love that show as
a big Breaking Bad fan I think better
call Saul is terrific
I am currently engrossed than I think
season for a better call Saul so I'm
very excited to see how that all plays
out and I've caught a little bit of
Goliath and really liked what I saw so
Joe well first of all I know that
everybody can find you all over the
place with your writing your podcasting
endeavors your hosting stuff I also want
to give a shout out to the show that you
produce nerd innocent which you
certainly adjudicated yourself as a
producer of a show called narrative
ascent
well here today where else can all the
kids out there find it yeah come check
out big dr. trill friends if you're into
a binge watch scrubs with me and Zack
and Donald it's been a lot of fun
producing that show as well definitely
check out Mary Davidson with Danny and
FEG we're doing a mental health May
month which has been a really exciting
and fun to learn about the science
behind a lot of mental health procedures
but you need an escape if you're looking
for a game of Thrones hi the last
Kingdom is gonna hit you real good it's
like a BBC production it's a whole bunch
of actors you've never seen which for me
is always very exciting because I like
to see like new faces and really get
immersed in the content it is about the
first king of England and also about
like Vikings and how Vikings came in
like settle the Saxons there are pretty
epic battles there are four full
glorious seasons you can binge on
Netflix I'm trying to take it slow and
not ruin it because every episode is
seriously so good guys it's well-written
it's funny it's dark and what I really
like about it is the aspects of magic
and gods is played as if you know that
they don't exist you have an advantage
in the world and yet at points in time
some people find them still slipping
they're like crap do I believe in God's
maybe we just make a sacrifice
Odin real quick just to keep everything
good you know and it's that sort of like
mind play that's just so good on the
women watch the left Kingdom and then
find me on Twitter and talk about it so
and when people talk about it with it's
so good well it sounds like Ben has his
homework cut out for him we can come
back here and debate that show so thank
you all once again for joining us and if
you've ever watched Game of Thrones you
know that usually there's a lot of
twists and falls fronts and turns and I
was worried about that here today but I
had nothing to fear because our amazing
tech crew made everything run so smooth
so thanks to everybody working hard for
us at Rotten Tomatoes behind the scenes
you're the true heroes of the show I am
just the face that apparently is still
there call me the queen of the north so
I'm gonna write that one out into the
sunset Thank You Joanna Thank You Ben
for everybody here at Rotten Tomatoes
I'm Mark Ellis thanks for watching
binge battle Game of Thrones edition
[Music]
[Music]